today we're checking out two new phones
from one plus the 1 plus 8 Pro and the 1
plus 8
we should probably unbox these first
yeah I know there are locks already
don't ask questions
[Music]
GamePro has a six point seven eight inch
120 Hertz qHD fluid display cold ComStat
dragon 865 processor it's five g
compatible and you can get up to 12 gigs
of ram plus 256 gigs of storage as a
4510 milliamp battery Wi-Fi 6 enabled a
quad camera and it comes in three colors
onyx black ultramarine blue and
interstellar glow the eight has a 6.5
5-inch 90 hertz fluid display also
running qualcomm snapdragon 865 with 5g
and also can be configured up to 12 gigs
of ram with 256 gigs of storage with a
triple camera setup this color is so
incredibly beautiful it actually took my
breath away I wasn't recording my
reaction when I opened this but if I was
it would have been something like this
and I love that it's kind of a matte
finish so the fingerprints are way less
visible than on the 1+8 but this color
if I didn't see this blue first this
interstellar glow has my name on it it's
got a really nice rainbow reflection
will get more into the phones in a
second but I've got some cases and one
of the new warp charge 30 wireless
chargers this is pretty great because
oneplus pro has a four thousand five
hundred and ten million battery so you
can charge one percent to fifty percent
in just a half hour with this new
wireless charger while the regular
oneplus doesn't have wireless charging
you can charge the 4300 milliamp battery
using the warp charge 30 T charger in 22
minutes you can go from 1 percent to 50
percent let's check out some of these
new cases
[Music]
yeah there we go that looks nice
this new quad camera is something that I
think everyone is gonna be really
excited about the 8 megapixel 3x
telephoto will give you up to 30 X
digital zoom plus enhanced optical image
stabilization the ultra wide is 48
megapixels it'll give you 120 degree
field of view it also features super
macro mode which you can capture images
up to 3 centimeters away the main camera
also is a 48 megapixel camera and the
color filter camera is 5 megapixels so
now that we're outside in my confined
backyard still got my house slippers on
because that's what we do here other
than just out the camera on the 1 plus 8
Pro here it is and I've got my beautiful
model here Maddie you looked better
clothes for mommy I'm mommy
are you handsome have you looked better
it's okay we all have obviously one of
the things that loves test out is video
so let's test this out we're actually
shooting us an HDR right now do you want
to tell us about your quarantine how is
it going let's focus on your little face
there we go
quarantine pups and I want to see what
it looks like if I'm fooling myself to
see how the wide-angle looks if I'm
filling myself vlogging one day we can
go outside again
I can't wait to vlog I've actually this
is all kind of maybe miss logging a
little bit just cuz I can't do it
classic Mady just cuz we can't do
something that makes us want to do it
even more
yep we're human so are you hey Yoshi
Yoshi asking Yoshi can test out test out
slow-mo mattiece it okay you're a dog
that doesn't listen okay so Maddie's not
performing so let me just think about
this I'll take a selfie in the meantime
this is portrait mode selfies okay just
take it regular one we take a picture of
my shoes
okay slippers this is 1x wide-angle and
3x zoom I mean hello
have you seen anything more fashionable
no you haven't
Maggie let's test out these color
filters okay so here we are this is
regular this is Matt look beautiful
vivid black and white and this is photo
Chrome how do you blinked we're gonna
test out macro mode so this you can get
of super close you can see the fibers
each tiny little thread I'm gonna do it
on my nose look at his nose
you can see everything gosh I do not
want to do that to my face the display
on the 1 plus a pro is really incredible
920 hertz refresh rate is really
impressive but it's light also has the
highest color accuracy ever on a 1 plus
phone it supports true-to-life colors
with HDR 10 plus it's 8 millimeters thin
you can configure it in two different
models an 8 gig or 12 gig much like most
phones that are iPhones it does have an
in display fingerprint sensor using
lpddr4 X Ram this allows the phone to
ramp up the memory speeds by 30% while
lowering power consumption by 20%
it has dual speakers powered by Dolby
Atmos with a new haptic vibration engine
this will allow your content and games
to feel more true to life with warped
charge you can go from 1 percent to 50
percent battery in a half hour with
their new Wireless warp charge 30 it
also has reverse wireless charging so in
23 minutes that can give you up to a 50
percent battery life using this phone
outdoors is really great because the
maximum brightness of the display is
1300 nits it also has an adaptive color
temperature with up to 4096 brightness
levels Jenna is now going to do a
run-through of all of these different
modes that we have to do some videos we
have the 4k 34k 62 4k cine 30 and 4k
City at 60 frames a second and of course
we have Maddy who you've seen who's not
really performing very well today I
think he just wants to sleep all day
saying alright Jen photos videos let's
start with video and then we'll roll
into the photos this my favorite color I
know no way
I know oh wow it's pretty nice my
goodness it's beautiful I know this is
me hello regular let's see wide angle
can you see these shoes no well now I
can he's diggin times 3 all right let's
see 4 K 60 and get you some slow-mo hair
look
[Music]
Pantene pro-v coffee the cinema club
gives us a 21-9 aspect ratio so we'll
get some really great cinematic shots
because it's what we need it's what we
need Jen so here it is you can tell that
the aspect ratio is definitely different
than the previous so let's let's let me
perform for you oh no I almost fell over
for k60 let's try it since this is 4k 60
cinematic let's do a cinematic fashion
show
shall we I'll do a walk
[Music]
the envelope
now we're take some photos I just
changed this to the 48 megapixels so
we'll be able to get higher quality all
right Johnny ready yeah so in the 48
magna pixel it won't give you a 3x zoom
so you're gonna have to switch back to
it we'll do an ultra-wide 48 and a
regular okay all right let's pop that
into the 12 megapixel and take all three
photos can you see my shoes yes one two
I'm falling we are really like left the
house in how many days you start to fall
so you can see like the blur vlogger see
some portraits Oh new profile pic who
dis is this real dramatic you look like
you just escaped no this is beautiful
that is art that's a photo to be proud
of it's pretty cool they also have a new
features there's a fourth camera on here
and it's a color filter this is actually
not just a filter this is the filter
that's built into the camera so I'm
gonna do tree pose by the tree
well thank you Jennifer demoing our
little photos here and video I
appreciate it but I thank you so much
for watching this was just a first look
at the 1 plus 8 and the 1 plus 8 Pro I
definitely look forward to testing this
out a little bit more especially when
we're able to leave the house I can take
this out and get some cool videos and
some cool photos for you guys but for
now this is my little quarantine review
of the 1+8 pro let me know if there's
anything else that you would like for me
to test out with this thing I love the
color I love the video I love the sound
of this bird sharp and quite loudly in
the background thank you I hear you
friend of God outside is so nice
I miss it out here come on you see
somebody shut up
do you know how to play the game boys
have you see someone yes show you baby
mommy's coming in hot headshot boom
headshot boom low ammo let's take it
this other team in there their trash
trash I got it all behind me
ha I didn't even see it the whole team
is behind me because I was too busy
trash-talking
if I'm not on kill cam I'd be very upset
there I am
anymore let's finish this video what